[Music]
Montana he's got like poison oak on his
butt yeah he's kind of got a rash going
welcome back to dirty arty this is
chapter 8 I believe yeah we're on eight
baby
we're on a we're cruisin so what's our
plan for this episode where we make
Arthur Morgan aka dirty already a big
POS butthole but muncher you know Jake
we've been thinking about it we want our
life back
ever since dirty already went down this
naked spiral he he needs his poor
features he needs a camp he needs most
importanly needs his lasso he needs his
lasso we don't really have a whole lot
when we're naked like this and it's a
tough life it's already a tough life
yeah it's too tough so we're gonna we're
gonna go back into town we're gonna go
to Valentine buy some clothes for start
right buy some clothes and then we're
gonna that we're gonna risk it all and
play some poker and see if we can buy
our life all $13,000 actually only thing
we gonna bet that high but we'll bet
everything we can yep we're gonna do
although I will say this is pretty
majestic watching him ride this horse
butt-naked his his long hair flowing in
the wind I can't help us always I've
told you this before I can't help but
think of like Oh runaway deer I can't
help but think of like plan of the Apes
yeah like just about his posture it
reminds me of like Caesar riding a horse
oh my god I don't need clothes do you
know we have some clothes on
hush nice throw
I mean no harm
yeah that's him boys I have I had to see
what this looks like
okay cuff me I dare you yeah it's
thinking about all the yeah you got a
lot to think about dirty Artie all right
let's go to the store and see what they
have for sale I'll start with
accessories okay okay get gloves right
yeah that's it that's all we need those
are those are Artie's classic gloves
shotgun chaps really accents my jaw yes
this of course this again one of the
criteria we have to we have to adhere to
is is the color has to have to get dirty
if we do dark and won't look at you're
right you're right so let's do this one
this is the brightest one there you go
we're good right that's all we need yep
cool yep that's it for what I have about
a hat oh yeah you're right
oh my god store clerk is doing his best
not to look at you that's okay I just
won't look at you then Bulldog or hat I
think that's I think that's pretty solid
yeah that's good I'm into it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the confidence in this dance is
mesmerizing this guy don't look at him
don't look so out of place oh is that a
pair of kings
oh that's pair kings we got a brave one
here three kings good yeah all right we
did it
let's celebrate
[Laughter]
Oh what the hell Oh what what the hell
what Jarek ah well back it was all a
dream
It was as if nothing happened what on
earth what a wild dream my dream I was I
was one with the countryside I was naked
and I was running and didn't have a
penis
using my invisible knife to make food
and didn't have a you know I was wearing
assless chaps and gloves and a hat but
I'm back I'm back and I'm craving some
rum you know Rob who you know you know
you know who drinks a lot of rum who
pirates
Oh duh yeah ah Rita are you telling me
that dirty Artie wants to become a
pirate I think so I think he was looking
through the comments of last episode as
he normally does he reads all of them
and insults those who insult him mm-hmm
and he saw someone said he should become
a pirate and he was he was like well I
could be a pirate I won't
I won't be powered how come I can't do
it I can do it that's right but if you
want to be pirate we need a pirate hat
well actually first we need to get that
donkey
we need a food we need a pirate hat and
a pirate sword and then Jake once we get
those crucial elements in order to have
you you can't be a pirate without a boat
you can't be up high with that boat and
you can't be a pirate at a crew so we're
gonna have to find ourselves some crew
members oh cool I think we're gonna
happen we're gonna see if we can get one
ideally two crew members oh just two I
mean we can do more than that so I'm
thinking once we get the boat we can
ride along like the coast and if we see
people just scoop them up I wish we knew
this donkey was here because I feel like
I left you saw I see it
okay what are you doing you think you
just sleep on the job you son of a [ __ ]
and he took the dog you get that's okay
the donkey knows where it's home is dude
that fall was unreal oh my god like jump
like not even six inches no yeah yeah I
should give the map of it you know what
though
like Ali survived that to tell the story
later he cut my leg look he got away we
just had like leave he was you freaking
us out
[Music]
our Tea Party
easy easy what the hell oh no we lost
Steve to keep an eye on the donkey
there's a goddamn believe we're at now
he will he walked into that that wasn't
my fault it was totally his fault oh my
god can you antagonize him from the
shore I can't
why won't let you I don't want to know
what he had to say but it's fine we'll
never know my donkeys Oh God yeah all
right bye donkey you sorta does well
mm-hmm I mean if you think about it
dirty Artie is doing the donkey a favor
yeah that's good point they would have
been able to survive out here all right
is it here somewhere mm-hmm it's in this
poker oh what's that
a just pirate rum perfect we got to save
that for a nice occasion you really do
look like a pirate
yeah like the long coat look at that
that rifle looks oldish hmm no no shoe
no shoes that that completes the pirate
look oh yeah my horse is dead and I
killed my donkey yeah definitely killed
the donkey I don't know if I could have
walked it off
[Laughter]
yeah yeah ok I'm gonna need that horse
oh he's gonna give me 100% was that just
take now I feel bad it's okay a pirate
captain Logan
that's right Captain Morgan
so one thing I did find out is that if
we go out of bounds with a boat it
automatically syncs so we have to be
careful with how far we venture out into
like the outer outer edges of the map
mm-hmm and most the bigger boats I've
noticed don't have anyone on them which
is kind of a shame it'd be cool if you
could jump aboard and like rob people on
it yeah but that's okay we'll stay near
the coast and we'll hassle people from
but also swords don't beat alligators as
I've learned oh wow
did not see him dude
[Music]
have a drink can I beat the Train nope
[Laughter]
yeah you gotta scary horses no hey
donkey no all right Farquaad what's that
trick or we could just do what are you
sure who are we kidding
this horse is gonna die within five
minutes okay gonna go I'm gonna stop by
the gun store so we can get ourselves
that we can get our get a twin for our
sawed-off shotgun you know I'm not gonna
lie it and maybe I'm gonna jinx it but
things are going really well okay
oh man part of me really wants you to
like buy this gun from this guy and then
just blow his head off but don't do it
God dial you really wanted to use it we
need a boat naturally wait till it
should we wait till morning
maybe maybe stop by our favorite bar
yeah yeah well so you're looking a
little clean nah didn't work we mud
y'all's dirt issue that valentine dirt
coming to the city Valentine got better
mother than sending me oh oh Jesus
barek oh no yeah Jerry cool are you
gonna cause problems sick sick sick sick
you did that really nicely do that very
well
well on the bright side we get to try
our new gun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got our hat we've got our sword
we've got our rum so if we go to the
docks sometimes it takes a little while
but we should be able to find oh man
hundred fifty bucks my horse got this
boat thing figured 30 yard he's a
natural pyrite he really is I'm a pirate
now just need to find my crew hey won't
be par with me hey hey you won't be a
par with me no too bad well that's too
bad
oh here we go this is one is so fast you
are white you're right Jesus you are
right well we got ourselves a boat now
we'll just need ourselves a crew
Wow talking [ __ ] that's fine that's fine
that's fine okay I don't care I don't
take that personally at all don't insult
my fashion don't you ever talk about my
hat I'm a pirate
so my plan is we get close to the shore
we see someone we want part of our crew
and then we'll just tie them up throw
them on board
easy I don't know how we'll throw them
on board Wolfie well cross that bridge
when it comes on pirate man we are
getting a lot of [ __ ] it's not cool
no one seems to care about to say that I
just torch the boat with like four dead
people and say whoa international waters
yeah anything goes we're gonna have some
friends I got everything I need and
laughs bye don't worry I got any friends
some crew members
I don't think we're gonna fit under here
if you just say pulp around here and go
to the road and let's just lasso some
people and put them on the boat maybe
you buy this house I'm gonna get my
pirate binoculars when looking looks a
little faking huh all right well
oh wait what's to the left scan zoom in
yeah what's over there
yeah people know it's a alligator okay
alligators
if you lasso him and then jump onto his
boat oh he knows he knows what's up it's
also not moving oh are you out of fuel
oh no oh no oh all right well that's
probably a good place to end it
dang well we didn't get a crew but we we
got we got ourselves a had a sword in a
boat and we hit the seas they weren't
meant for us but that's fine
hey with that I'm dirty already stay
tuned for another episode next week
thank you guys see you guys have a great
time we got dumbass [ __ ]
you